To Mister Reg Saunders, who worked as a youth and apprentice stonemason at the quarry at Maria during the building.
The Sydney Harbour Bridge do remember first getting the job done solace yes and buried the Richard Park.
I was induced to I was induced to undertake the five-year apprenticeship on my father 's advice.
For this reason that there is life were consisted of the arduous labour a how he had no trade
and who used to say to me that traits and have the great advantage over the ordinary labourer
and the tea therefore suggested that I be one of one of the year.
A number of boys
but would undertake an apprenticeship to become a granite Mason did you live down there before the view I opened it in.
I am a native of Maria farm.
My father was the morning Maria in the year eighteen seventy three and I was born in the year nineteen hundred
and nine, which makes me in my early seventies today,
particularly the quarry of media normal along with the executive body are publicised in the local press are the
opportunity of learning the granite trade founder several of my schoolmates responded together with myself,
founder for a year.
The first procedure was to have ourselves legally examined to see if our lungs were sufficiently strong to stand up to
the arduous labour that was in nineteen twenty seven, was it I would say you are nineteen twenty six.
I actually started my apprenticeship in nineteen twenty six, together with the all the other boys,
that was the year that the year, workers compensation came in
and that the rule is the rule that you are getting lemon between Intertrade Lachmann of illicit letters are interesting
to me.
I did not serve no lap to until the rich adjuster mentioned it to me,
but it is imperative that day of the health of the men in the various trades be so protected under place
and we boys upto local doctor to be passed is medically fit to undertake the arduous trade to member starting what you
have to do in the first place when you started the leader of the initiation of the word,
the initiation of a stonemason is a bloody business excuse my using media, an Australian colloquialism.
It was a bloody business in this regard, but after the first skill
but was necessary was to be able to strike are the tool.
I will punch
or chisel the strike at our weather for pound hammer they were the idea of making some impression on the granite well
you were conformed truly instruction of the master mason than you went at it well.
It is a most awkward thing to learn the ABC of anything in the biggest problem was allowed to hit the head of that
punch or chisel or a pure rudeness member, you would get a go on
and you'd get more confident than the more confident you became the harder you would hit until a critical moment would
the crop up when instead of hitting the head of the punts you would mess and hit your hand
and hence my use of the word bloody because he would not propitious skin off your hand as big as a shilling piece
and the blood would the flow profusely so get all over your tool and all over your hand founder of the matter of fact,
I nearly fainted the first shock of IMC by having myself with this hammer and furthermore,
though the initiation period would go on to say three months.
In other words, you would never be sure of hitting the head of that tool.
Until three months have elapsed, and even then you would sometimes miss and the pram
but have been lacerated previously would have been healing up nicely and all of a sudden you would bash it
and opened up again and that was the excruciating point of use and Lilly make me think that the pain.
Hence my initiation was a first aid, therefore, that the thing.
Yes, indeed, founder of
or your attention to an incident which I actually saw happen working opposite me was one of the original Masons it came
over from the big horn country of Canada, whose name is George Wharton Scotchman, full-blooded
and George was one day are standing on his per block of granite up on its end
and the electric crane driver have the list tonnage or are suspended Faye about a foot off the ground
and George want placing a block underneath the endless bone in order to get a good it properly settle down
and the dogs came out and George, instead of having his plans and four
and on the block of wood who have one hand over the top of the block in one and underneath and
when the dogs came out the stone came down and onto his hand
and I saw George is swinging back away from the falling stone a holding his hand,
and one of his fingers have been crushed off allowed yours was in was a man of over fifty I been over sixty,
yet the fortitude of that man amazed me because he walked down to the first aid to which Richard has just referred
people download first aid are stationed about a distance of four five hundred yards holding his crushed finger
and no sign of going out to it as an expression Gödel.
Finding no decision out of our next city get involved in any yourself.
I know I I didn't get involved in any bad ones,
but on my finger here I'll draw Richards attention to a scar on my finger where you can see,
it are rigid scar set that wide scar ball on this particular day I was holding a cool
and my fellow apprentice was striking the head of this tool and the EU the granite
or the suddenly all of a sudden burst
and the piece went up in their I held my right hand over my head to protect my head.
Her that the the brownish got my finger, which was rushed been the handle of the stool hourly of the scar until list,
they look at it.
It almost got my finger off, what a minor incident has sidelined concern I like now to refer to our an accident,
but a tragic accident.
I remember vividly you are the circumstances of an accident,
a fatal accident that occurred in the face of the quality of my brother in law mainly George what the Scotchman was
working with a number of his mates and under there was no year,
a huge block of granite are up on alleged it had been blasted out the ready for the dimension cutters on the floor of a
quarry and all of a sudden something caused this block of granite to lose its equilibrium and it fell it fell down
and as it did so are my brother-in-law is make namely that Percy Poole and incidentally,
Mister Percy Poole 's name is record of on the plight of the northern pylon
and one of those men who were was killed her in the Maria quarry rollout of a policy pool didn't get away from the face
of the quarry quick enough Easter back against the face, thinking it could avoid the tonnage of branded
and still that the granite fell back on him crushed him against the face.
My brother-in-law George what was a young young Mandela not after before his wage depict Percy Poole up
and carried him out of the face.
The other was a tragic accident shall just referred to without a fatal accident at the quarry another fatal accident
was to one on the crimes that was driven by a Scotchman named Joe 's civil rights are his dog man was a contemporary of
my fathers Mister Morton hurry water
or hurry waters was riding on media leader body of the tray of the crying in a under some right.
Didn't see him sitting there and set right the Swanley, you claim around at a given point
and the Mister Waters was crushed his side a was crushed and that was another major accident, Germany. Other ones.
Not that I can call there were surprisingly few accident at the Maria Quarry can remember what term what your job was
whether you are a bit
and printers they could you explain it publisher what I've been longing to do because there has been a great deal of
publicity concerning the steel work over construction of the bridge, but little
or nothing has been set down all spoke on concerning the actual learn processing of the granite in Maria
and this is what I've been longing to do the eye
but better go back to where I have to describe the actual acquiring of the skill of striking the tool without missing
it.
I was about to describe more extensively part of the initiation
and it suits a bloody year are well low effects on the apprentice will now in the sheds are our first own world lined
up twelve feet apart and are there were four rows of men.
There were two sheds and four rows of men,
and there were four are compromised their to this I would say these tube would be about six inches in diameter hours
tubes around the full length of this shed was the sheds
and from those to reserve was extended to each individual Mason,
a rubber hose onto which he could screw his pneumatic tools.
I'd like to emphasise that they'd is practically impossible to work granite unless you have pneumatic tools they are
under this was the year of the technique employed by the Masons in their leave the mention the leading quarry man was a
like a leaving dimension cutter he would doubt reduce the block of granite that had been blown down into the floor of
Macquarie, he would reduce it and get from that block of granite, a maximum number of style with a minimum of waste
when and how to achieve that end he would mark was stung by the number on the stone
and the steam train would pick up start up
and carry it to a end of the shed where it would be picked up by one of the electric cranes and courage down
and deposit into what ever Banker are was empty in which the Mason operated every mason had his own particular optical
banker well what was a bank Banco make or a position position every man nerve respectively on Banco hiccup to it
and the penalties up his own set of tools were which he valued very much
and the lists granite block around would be deposited in his banker
and over the next procedure would be the shed for the shed.
Former owner owner Mister Hatton trick to click on May he was the brother in law of the drama leading draft man who
name with William Mollison well that in effect would bring to this particular Mason,
a design that have been drafted by his brother-in-law in the office
and he will hand up the design over to the motion and the motion would proceed.
Accordingly,
as amended all the stones were different all-weather number the same of there were a number the same that what was the
sickening monopoly on the trade.
The repetition that very little variety us what that's what got my goat to use a common expression.
The sickening monotony of one stone after another, and the arduous labour is a deadly at it it Worley down
and broke my heart was also nurses said they were restarted different.
I don't know quite what to not every style,
learned a lot depends upon the change in the architecture if we refer the architecture of a year structure is very
varied.
Well needless to say the stones that would be cut accordingly would vary to,
but you can see for yourself the continuity of their face work on the pylons is very much the same known for many many
courses before Gazza before any change is us.
It is about mornings but five or six different bangles of to places, but to have quite a lot to get it now.
Our fellows before our leave the stoned trade is undoubtedly one of the oldest of trades
and was nothing set bounding the textbooks from which you could learn to become a Mason,
you had to learn in practically you have to go to the Mason himself and learn the skill of handling the tools
and so forth.
While now in this masonry trade one of the fundamental principles the basic principle in fact was to be able to do so
create a given plane.
It have to be as near as possible
and the to-do lists the Scotsman uses a well son would not attract the twist out of the start on the coast meant that
the earth.
The facial was known or she were going to create this given plane like a table top floor bump interest
and so forth were for you.
How to create that given plane because the whole accuracy of this dull
and dependent upon the creation of that original plan.
The foreman stonemason who cut the starting tool world usable blocks to use her hammer
and which is auditing also use soars all the
or what well immediately form in the mason in the quarry unity was what are called early the leading her quarrymen on
Imam dimension cutter far as he was given certain specifications of the hat.
The work to pander seaward over the drop the Lions when I say drop the lines they use a chalk line is
and they will drop a line from top to bottom on this line would rob virtual red chalk on alignment drop the line the on
the lion,
the media are drilled men Macquarie men use of more series of holes light Asus thousands of whole use of the board
leaseholds would be saved four inches deep by a diameter would you be so pass your first finger bound around the these
holes were bored safe four inches apart light on the line now injury each individual hole was placed to this day you
will are feathers they were flat on one side and oval on the other male.
The quarry mound would insert in between those feathers up like a steel plaque that fitted neatly and
when he got all these who was unplugged lined up he within start with the town hammer
and tighten up many would pick up for of, say, six pounds six pound hammer and would begin to strike more heavily well,
it was it was it was magnificent to see the effects of the pressure of loaf plugs struck uniformly
and how those plugs and fellas would open up the granite and the split would go down six and eight
and ten foot deep longer.
This process take one jot are well its father 's determined mapped there would be perhaps three
or four men clear for machines to working on the one big block of granite under the light directional relieving the
dimension cut by sewage ministry several of her hitting their feathers in yet several several of them would be boring
the holes and inserting these plugs
and feathers so according to a predetermined lines by the leading a dimension cutter.
but In blast at all the Macquarie
but no other tunnel unless a court further away required the are embellished to be crushed by the big crusher,
which was operating on the floor of the quarry.
They used to have held such blasting in the in the font Forum McQuarrie, but this was done during the meal out
when all other men were away out of the quarry and was safely a precaution adopted
and they were bought at individual hole in each of these big dollars pieces and loaded with dynamite
and you would have a series of explosions in the quarry during the lunch hour
and this would break up Leo waste which was beat would be transported and put into the big crusher in the bed of hot,
but in so. In fact be the blocks that you made the forty thousand.
Block that you made were not actively blasted out at all originally.
They are the material from which they were made the ruling material was blasted out of the facelift facial McQuarrie
and that was the that was the only year in the skill of the quarryman to get out of bigger big a piece of granite out
of the face without shattering it so that when the dimensions cutters started to work on.
They were no faults would you remember then they are the cutting of the two thousand tonne block for the year,
Senator Arthur Martin Place, yes indeed, so I, I was walking in the quarry are
when the latter are block of granite was especially blowing out of the face
and it was that large media steam crane operating on the floor of the quarry couldn't to her hand with do very well,
but nevertheless they didn't send our Mason out of the shed to work that the solid laughs bone on the floor of the
quantity and whose name was an Italian Calder 's Europe want to Europe want Dick Q.
Did she old knew him well
and I'm oh describe someone about this mounted as of specific interest to smoked in are like a furnace
and who couldn't he couldn't to get sufficient satisfaction out of smoking his though extremely strong pipe to use to
one end you could be quite a way to cool for a while.
It would take his penknife and the pickup in his pipe and out of the bottom of the bowl of the pipe,
he would do this saturated nicotine saturated director of tobacco and into his hand.
He put that and make it into a ball, London: in his mouth
and chill it now that nicotine DIY I've given you understand there's enough to turn our lizard or ago and only back,
but it had no effect contribute your what proportion of Italians were there.
There were proportionately speaking very small, then the sum of the universe.
The writings I have done on this subject are in fact to make myself quite accurate on my subject.
I looked into the old photographs
and I know these Italian as I knew these Battalion as well as I do have a note on what my on face
and I counted twenty twenty Italians,
the great majority of them were in a full-blooded Scotchman Pamela Scott well independent evidence is very often more
impressive.
My friend of Mister Kohl factions to Bob cold fax this open, but they were one hundred and on that one hundred
and there were twenty. At least Italians right sale via the balance would be Australian.
There were very,
very few the Italian are rather Australian masons might in our half a dozen that Australian masons are the lady who
worked in the office bearer holiday are that in Sydney. She used to do the wages source user checked wages familiar.
She seems to remember that there was round about two hundred and fifty colour faxes got tea reckons two hundred
and forty altogether, only at the quarry are on the general sort of opinion was that they were split three ways,
but you will reckon that they were less in actual fact are less Italians on the twenty yes,
I'll do you remember our home.
The Scotsman
and the families of the Scots people came out indeed I do because those years were the formative years of my life.
We're impressionable years are my parents had the broken up their marriage
and are our family had been split up to the mercy of the waves under my father
and I were living well batching together by under my life seemed to be a continuous negation.
I was deprived of the natural fiction that day the sun will expect from our mother deprived of that and are oh
when I had the the opportunity of socialising with these Scotch people in their downfalls and so forth.
Many of those women used to thought of our well so are my ear the conference by under it was then that the I felt that
life was worth living idea began to realise that the life was not as a barrier as Sir, I had anticipated.
In fact I can safely say that Dana via example of the Scotch people are influenced my life form that they still less.
I look upon the Scottish people as being people of sterling qualities splendid moral characters do remember the year
Caledonian Society dancers than the collapse of the largest briefly touching on, though I well remember them when
when laypeople settled at paragraph Talbot was the name of their village.
They have no were whole or in which they could carry on their functions and so on a Friday night at least once a month,
they would have a Caledonian Society Downs up in Maria Tao
and it was a grandiose site to see these people going through all the violations of these Scotch dancers are similar
gases were well outstrip the willow the eightsome reel before some real the Highland fling you learn to do it is our
RDI on our aim is simply to too complicated.
They were figured answers are no too complicated for me there highlands shot these will another undersea these people
at their age as many of them almost problem were middle-aged people and older,
and to see these people dancing furiously the way they did reminds me of product our raw Robert Burns 's poem,
the Tamil Shanter where the situation is described very, very vividly I sought an actual life, Germany,
humorous stories about very earned the quarry are those well,
I don't remember many are not my friend Mister Kohl faction relates in his history, namely memory lane.
He relates is drawing their about her Scotchman who had below on his own idea of receiving his our wages less rent that
it had to pay, but I can't go into detail about that.
It is all embodied in Mister Cole faxes story memory lane,
but I will mention one little liar our incident that happened to me personally I was working away one day there are
structural and came up to me
and instead be on all what I did Nick Chin man signing power shall I don't voice ideogram were like terminate,
you know. Do you know what it may have been about them.
Yes, I know very well now,
having studied Robert Burns were so many years quite familiar with the structure of the language various to you can now
getting Tommy given the working conditions down there and around the grief
and in the stern dressing sheds only too well either gone and into that one.
I was so describing how to create a given plan from which the rest of the stone is Sir are made from right part you had
to set up on each corner of the Stalin a position with your hammer niches will you would create this position on the
four corners of the stone and on each of these corners were we were given a steel to slow twelve inches high
and always the little before parishioners deal will exactly the same height
and how to put them on the zircons of the stone founder recall pegs across these packs were put straight edges found
the object was to create three positions on the staff
and before one at the beat adjusted according to the other three so you would get go on in the end of look at
illustrated edges under you would get the straightahead should by repeatedly chilling this particular was the third
or other fourth position by comfortably repeatedly mentioning it down go down gradually,
and finally getting your pneumatics you'll underwritten being inaccurately
and by looking only at the straight edges from time to time you will ultimately get those all corners of on the stone
accurate than you were ready to start drafting between the points
and that was important point you have to create a draft all around us down form of this given plane to listen so forth
with your punch first to get the rough off after the punch of big up your hands is all the hammer
and you would take the draft flew a hand chiselled lineal took them down and even you would take your pneumatic tool.
I was missed that teachers would use it up in it
and then you wouldn't take that third draft down with the pneumatic chisel right down working constantly with the
straight edge which would be created all around the stumble
and about those overdraft around you had a big heap of what you perceive
and how much rock you had to get off to get down to that that given plain
and that it sometimes is of that was astounded to be that rough,
we shall have to get the drilling machine on what are some rough water first founder loom are frequently those stones
will in in most cases though stones were sent out drafted out into this surfacing machine area where all the rock was
taken off by a big surf fishing machine that operate on alarm operator mama arm in this arm could provide around on
this vertical spindle and the pneumatic tool was about six is injured inches in diameter.
It was controlled by the operator to any position on that surface
and the gradually he would wear it all down with a special tool,
which was inserted in the head of the pneumatic tool called a four.
List for point was tempered by the tool sharps in the blacksmith shop in such a way that the points would not snap
and therefore the operator would push the machine at all over this surface
and taken take new gradually down to the draft
and finally he would put in in the in the pneumatic tool in lieu of the four-point who put for cuts before cut out for
blatant and by holding that of the fork up on by the handle
and controlling meet their actual body of the dramatic tool he would direct this fork at all over the surface
and bring the surface, right down to the drafts,
so that's what is known as Peyton for cut work natural gas in the harbour.
The rock face, which was on the front are you now rock face that was different.
There are no such procedure necessary in the producing the rock face that was a relatively simple operation.
All you have to do was to pay attention to Leo cutting of the beds in the joints of the stone
and they have to be worked down to work the drafts phoned the media.
A recent don that library block of granite that was produced in that shed was faced up according to eight double there
was a top bid Bevel and the bottom bed Bevel and we had usually battles
when are finishing off the face of a start on under I remember the year the bubbles were eighty degrees eighteen
degrees what the bigger under the ninety degree without gas and eighty degrees founder,
we had to cut the youth face of the stay on the rock face of that of the granite accordingly bubbles of most important,
because if you observe the these structure of those pylons.
I am not perpendicular
but they are on a bevel that is what every individual stone was so cut it as a number of different levels as well
because if you look at the at the front face onto the bridge.
It starts up, but is an acute angle really gradually gets even more of trips and Cuba mat in
and around the sides are slightly different accountability quite a number of different levels you are quite right,
particularly the big stones down the base 's man told the pylon 's way were cut very acutely
but they are very much bigger heavier than the stones that do worse a mounted on the yes that the bevelled did a very
is also quite a number of key stones in the archers are part of the way up the pylons as well.
It'll thought the shapes.
Yes, indeed those keystones and to the magnificence the majesty of the stone structure, those keystones
and all the various towns I forget these technical aim on that graduates
but graduate up up on each side of Argentina will make on verge on the keystone.
This is one of my arch of masonry to be able to draft out
and cut accurately the arched islands did you work on any of the year of the stones for the vicinity after to know
though it was stoned as I said earlier the Senate passed on was the cut in the better the quarry by a few upon deep Q.
Did she.
Oh, and it was finally our eye surfacing machine was taken into the union body and set up alongside this great though.
Massive granite and the surfacing machine finish the star often in the bed of the quarry
and I have nothing to do with that. It was also twenty Street in addition to the large alter Stonier talking about.
There was also twenty three base stones.
That's what I was asking whether you had in his ability never now know is mounted on twenty three stones underneath
there is one of the stone on the top of this is news to me.
Well,
I can safely save it as a very creditable a monument to read Phil coming down that a cat that's the into Maria Arnaud I
don't remember that particular day part,
but I did see Doctor Brad feel on several occasions come down to visit the quarry with Mister Innis because you
remember the quarry manager, indeed I do know if you don't mind me year tumbling myself
and the speaking of the my dear irresponsible low in a way of life.
I will enter into it as briefly as I can and I said earlier, though our family life had broken up under my father
and I were living together in my life was more or less a life of negation of deprived a lot
but my father being a Melbourne minded man who tried to make up for the loss of my mother founder to remember the
quarry manager, yes I do only too well far as I stated earlier in our family life.
Life had broken up and consequently I was very, very happy and myself
and what we were arduous labile I had to face up to a day by day, plus the negation of my domestic life well,
I was very upset young fellow pander far I have served about two and a half years of my time
and I began to see you my future wife in the right perspective,
namely nothing else would do well near slavery to my way of thinking, and I said the will.
I'm going to get out of this slave shop and get away into the city were low.
The work will be proper for me to become a finished craftsman found out what with what the what with radio Scotland are
saying to me also unilateral use of the tools he is certainly
but you're not getting enough experience to become a qualified unmanned properly of your best ideas to get away to the
city will have a better chance well,
I became so discontented in myself that I became were in different irresponsible rubble in other words, and under.
I can see myself in the right perspective.
Now I ought not to have conducted myself that way, but it was my only way out and so I wouldn't work.
I used to doing my pleased and I caught of the disfavour of Mister Gilmore Borrie manager,
manager of the quarry manager and Leo is executive staff,
wherein the officer applied to the year to conciliation committee of the trade Paul that govern apprenticeship matters
to her mind ventures counselled on the grounds of Llewelyn what will the terms of disobedience shallow fullness
negligence which was entirely justified victory committee wrote back to me and asked me,
I show any reason why my indents should not be cancelled and I wrote back and set I'd be very,
very pleased if they were counselled and they were promptly cancelled Nick
and I remember the day that Mister Gilmore are instructed that I come over in the office because I was a centre of fur
disrespected disregard by all these Scots men and I felt though quite ashamed, but I have to face up to
and I went on about a Nice edited subdued down first word out of his mouth were, what do you think of yourself
and I said well, Mister Gilmore as far I can see it all for the best known research looked everyone your career.
You'll never get recognise in Sydney.
If you are stating this firm,
you have been Arab enabler travel all over the world unacknowledged as a fully qualified the Mason and so forth.
Now you now you've ruined it all.
Well, Mister Gilmore said that all remains to be seen and I was only eighteen when I said that they and any help.
I left them with a good race but crestfallen
but I will say this though Mister Gilmore has a reputation unchristian believe are first class.
but Of course the altercation I had with Mister Gilmore creates in my mind,
another impression that under that in the was justified because it was bad.
It was he was entirely justified in dispensing my services for reasons I've outlined
but subsequently Mister Gilmore by all my father up and inveigle my father and
or situation be wanted my father to condemn me, but my father being unknowable natured man
and the democratic manner partly was he stood by me and he sue it back into the tea for Mister Gilmore for so doing.
Mister Gilmore fact my father now is no justification whatsoever for so doing whatever little given well.
I came to Sydney
and it was indeed the saddest day of my life because I been associated with my father from birth up to eighteen years
of age and we were living in the account up behind according.
I know very well the set up camp were batching their founder.
It broke my heart to have to say goodbye to my father up there during one lunch hour I was going up into the township
to book my fear on the bus to narrow into Sydney are several more.
I had to say goodbye to my file there and then
and the iron I know now how my father 's heart breaking that they will my father was sacked not though being a native
of the district. He will able to continue getting a livelihood pander.
He went into a market garden which was on a farm immediately opposite,
whether Quarry was not only was the family name was drawn draw out of my father took up wound their inform the market
garden so he managed.
I wrote it management by when the Sydney
and under Lizard won my real education began by year 's had no worm convictions in my wife being so young.
I have no solid convictions about anything. One conviction. I did though take we must heart was oppression.
I have seen my father 's wedding in the bush cutting logs
and squirting sleepers I've seen in the out on the farms walking up
and down between the rows of corn scuffling corn in the heat in the dust.
I used to say to myself, well if ever I start work and can learn a few pounds, I should.
I'm going to take some this burden off my father well to revert back I came to Sydney
and Mister Gilmore is the prophecy was ill founded ill founded. Because I went to the union and the unit.
Secondly, said the media Wally said that you completed completed two and a half years of your time
and they don they didn't think they going to spoil your career as simple as all this, it said.
I will draft a letter for you and you go out with this letter to Mister Ross at Waverley Cemetery and ROI.
I took that letter
and Mister Ross didn't hesitate to earth to engage me as his apprentice for the rest of my time on big strong
and I finished my apprentice ship there in the monumental yard at Waverley Cemetery,
where I had a good opportunity we or work during the depression.
Yes,
indeed I finished my partnership in the middle of the patient by storm in fully qualified men with years of experience
coming in and out of that monumental yard making the right of employment.
Nothing doing when I came alike time the depression was at its height.
I have no choice but to go on the fall and can only dole for shillings
and ten Penny Doll I went on that I have no choice
but under it as if it is a tragic Kerr episode in my life I had a friend far he would perform on the Waverley Council
but Wally Wally Evans by name Wally Evans,
a Welsh I was a well registered the best I can do for you is given to each attempt in my backyard bander is